il refuse de les voir dormir dehors une
vingtaine de bénévoles s'est rassemblés
ce matin devant la mairie de dole
ils soutiennent 17 familles avec 34
enfants déboutés de leur demande d'asile
et qui doivent quitter leur logement
aujourd'hui les bénévoles exige qu'un
hébergement d'urgence soit trouvée
rapidement
comme il semble qu'il n'y ait pas
beaucoup d'autres solutions pour le
moment qu'il ne soit proposé bien on
vient interpeller le maire et on lui dit
c'est une catastrophe humanitaire qui
arrive ce matin à dole il faut donc
qu'une cellule d'urgence répondent à
cette catastrophe
ces dix sept familles parce que l'année
scolaire est finie on estime qu' on
n'atteint plus on ne porte plus
atteintes aux droits de l'enfant et donc
on peut les mettre dehors
mais le droit de l'enfant de coucher
dehors je crois que aucun parent ne
l'admet une délégation a été reçue en
mairie ce matin si aucune solution
concrète mais trouver certains militants
sont prêts à dormir devant la mairie
sion